لترانزيت عشرين مليون طن من
السلع سنويا وروسيا طلبت رفع
الحجم الى خمسين مليون طن.
الاحداث والتطورات. تتجه انظار
مهلة اربع وعشرين ساعة لمغادرة
الدبلوماسيين الايرانيين. اما في
الاسرائيلي يزور واشنطن للضغط
باتجاه عدم احياء الاتفاق النووي
راما السفير الايراني وموظفي
السفارة الايرانية وجميع
تهديدا صريحا لايران بعمل عسكري
اسرائيلي لوقف برنامجها اما
الخلافات البحرية غير مفيدة
داعية البلدين الى تسوية
كورونا الى تركيا لتؤكد لانقرة
على اهمية عدم تحايل شركاتها على
الاوكرانية ستنتهي في وقت قريب.
واقول للمستخفين بروسيا انتم
الايرانية لم يعد لهم مكان هكذا
طرد رئيس الوزراء الالباني ايدي
الخلافات بطرق سياسية ودبلوماسية
فحرب التصريحات لا تحل مشكلة.
العقوبات الغربية على روسيا بعد
ان قالت الولايات المتحدة ان
الاعمال الروس الجنسية التركية
ويخلص الثوب الروسي ليتملص من
مخطئون. فهي ليست دولة يستخف
بها. اعتقد ان اوروبا ستواجه هذا
متجاهلا تحذيرات الغرب. ليضيف
ليبدو ان الحرب الروسية
قائمة على الاستفزاز. اني ارى
بوصلة اردوجان تميل للطرف الروسي
الجيش الروسي لهذا النوع من
الصواريخ وذلك خلال مناورات
تغضب واشنطن. وعلى خطى الباسوس
نانسي بيلوسي وصل وفد من
الاسرى روسيا تعجل في التفاوض
والهدف والملقب بتاجر الموت.
وخسائر اوروبا تصل عنان السماء.
ومن المؤشرات الاقتصادية الى
اساءت بنفسها لسمعتها. فماذا
يقصد هنا باختصار كوني لا احب
فبماذا سيرد الرئيس التركي
اردوغان على واشنطن. ايران تحت
الى انخفاض الثقة في الدولار
واليورو والجنيه الاسترليني فقد
مستقلة مع شركائها. بوتين يضيف
كل الحبوب التي تم تصديرها من
ظهر الرياح. ليشتم الاخر رائحتها
ويعلم الهدف منها فلغة البارود
ولا يدري اين يذهب بعد ان انتهى
من القاء خطاب ليصبح بايدن من
روسيا مستحيل. وشدد على ان موسكو
ستسعى لحماية مصالحها سياسات
العمال. انتشر مقطع فيديو لبايدن
ايضا وهو تائه يسأل عن الطريق
اكثر رؤساء العالم لسجل حافل من
الهفوات منذ توليه الرئاسة.
العربية. كل انسان له الحق بان
يكون احمقا هذا ما نعت به الرئيس
الاوكراني يوجه رسالة عاجلة
لبوتين وفرنسا تغضب بكين بهذا
الانسداد السياسي في البلاد.
الجزائر ترسل مبعوثا خاصا الى
برأيكم هل سيوقف بوتين شريان
الغذاء بعد ان اوقف شريان
المغرب لتوجيه دعوة حضور القمة
العربية المقررة في الجزائر
طهران استهدف مؤسسات وشركات في
الدولة. واعطت السلطات الالبانية
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان
الرئيس التركي لليونان بشأن
الامريكي جو بايدن احد المعترضين
اثناء خطاب القاه بمناسبة عيد
الدبلوماسيين الايرانيين من
البلاد بعد هجوم سيبراني نفذته
الحليف الروسي فعلاقته بايران
تزداد متانة اذ قال وزير الطرق
لدعوات الى جميع ملوك وامراء
ورؤساء الدول الاعضاء في الدول
السويدية. ومن الحرب السيبرانية
الى الحرب النووية. رئيس الموساد
واعمار المدن الايراني رستم
قاسمي ان هنالك عقدا مع روسيا
السويد فقد اتهم تقرير
استخباراتي سويدي بالحصول على
مع ايران. وكان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي ايرلبيد قد وجه
النار. اطردوا السفير الايراني
وكل العاملين في السفارة
قرارها بشأن طلب التيار الصدري
حل البرلمان في ظل استمرار ازمة
العراقيين الى المحكمة الاتحادية
العليا التي المفترض ان تصدر
العقوبات المفروضة. كترت
الانتهاكات ليصرح حفيد عثمان
معلومات خاصة بتصنيع السلاح
النووي والتجسس على التكنولوجيا
شركات تركية تواجه خطر التعرض
للعقوبات فقط ياخذ بعض رجال
العاصمة. وسيتم ارسال مبعوثين
الى العواصم العربية حاملين
البرلمانيين الفرنسيين الى
تايوان في اول زيارة رسمية والتي
الدولار الامريكي من الاسواق
العالمية? تهديد تركيا الاخير.
ومدحه لبوتين الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان يعود من جديد ليصرح
الصيني والروبل الروسي. اذا نجحت
هذه الخطوة ستكون اقرب للموضة
ولا تتمنى واشنطن ان تخوض معها
هذه اللعبة. نعم يا سادة انها
هنا وبعد هذه التصريحات تتوجه
وزيرة الخارجية الفرنسية كاترين
ويلمح لعملية عسكرية وشيكة ليأتي
الرد من واشنطن وعلى لسان ادارة
بوتين وصف هذا الحدث بانه تاريخي
ليس لاسواق الطاقة العالمية فحسب
بل لروسيا والصين كذلك. وسبق
لروسيا ان وقعت اتفاقا مع الصين
مجددا قائلا صبرنا له حدود.
اردوغان يوجه تحذيرات لليونان
تزايد في الاونة الاخيرة ليزداد
معها الدعم الامريكي للقوات
التايوانية لترد بكين بلعبتها
المفضلة والتي تجيد المراوغة بها
بقيمة اربعمائة مليار برأيكم هل
ستنجح الصين وروسيا بكسر قاعدة
ويقصد هنا جهنم. تصريح جدلي من
الرئيس الاوكراني فمصير الاخرة
الاقتصادية. وهذا ما يخيف
واشنطن. الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
قد ستة ايام وذلك بدعوة من حكومة
تايوان. لا تخبروني ان الصين
قائلا السياسة التي يتبعها الغرب
تجاه الحرب الروسية الاوكراني
الشتاء مشاكل خطيرة وحقيقية بشأن
امدادات الغاز. ليدخل شيطان الشك
البداية في الحرب الاوكرانية.
تهديدات اصحاب العيون الضيقة
محسسني انك رايح مارينا ما كلكم
رايحين ليها يا روح امك. الصين
لا يكفي ولن يشفي غليل وباللهجة
المصرية كما هي العادة الا انت
لعبة الاقتصاد. روسيا والصين
تتقدمان خطوة نحو النظام العالمي
تدريبات ومناورات بالذخيرة الحية
تعيد بنا الاذهان الى نقطة
وقبل ان تنتهي اربع وعشرون ساعة
على تصريحاته الساخرة من الغرب
سترد بمناورة عسكرية كما هي
عادتها ادخنة الاسلحة التايوانية
الكلامي. بوتين مجرم حرب ويجب ان
يحاكم قبل ذهابه الى الجحيم.
لنعد الى رائحة البارود مجددا
ولاول مرة في تاريخ الجيش الروسي
صاروخ اونيكس يحلق في السماء.
وهنا مقطع مصور يظهر لحظة اطلاق
من الغاز الى اوروبا حتى يرفع
الغرب عقوبات الاقتصادية. بوتين
الجديد. صفقات بالمليارات يغيب
فيها الدولار ليغطي غيابه اليوان
مؤشرات المفاوضات الدولية. نائب
وزير الروسي سيرجي وفي تصريح
الى مزيد من الارتفاع في
الاسعار. واعتبر بوتين ان عزل
وذلك من اجل اتمام الحوار مع
الولايات المتحدة بشأن تبادل
عاجل يطالب واشنطن بالاسراع في
اصدار التأشيرات لاعضاء وفدها
وببزته العسكرية ها هو يلقي
التحية على الطاقم ليتسلم هو
النفط والغذاء في تلميح واضح انه
قد يطلب تحديث بعض الشروط الخاصة
تتصاعد ليتصاعد معها التهديد
الصيني في الليل والنهار.
هي اللغة التي يتحدث بها. حدة
الازمات بين روسيا واوروبا
الدفة ويشرف على مناوراته
العسكرية. نعم ها هو ياخذ ناظوره
مسائل الرياضيات والاقتصاد روسيا
تضرب في مقتل ولكن بدون دماء
ترسل مبعوثا للمغرب والسفير
الايراني يتعرض للطرد من هذه
العسكري ليتأكد من ايصال رسالته
هي لم تكتب بالحبر بل تحمل على
اوكرانيا ذهبت لدول اوروبا.
ليؤكد بوتين ليس فقط النفط بل
بوستوك الفين واثنين وعشرين.
ليرد زيلينسكي بهذا الصاروخ
تتصاعد خلال الساعات الماضية مع
تأكيد موسكو على ايقاف امداداتها
يصرح. محاولات تحديد سقف الاسعار
للغاز الروسي في اوروبا ستقود
بنقل الحبوب هي لده وخبثك يا ابن
الكريمل. واضاف ايضا كل الدلائل
الدولة فما هو السبب? رسائل
بوتين المرعبة. بخطواته المتزنة
صبري بدأ ينفد فماذا ستعمل ان
نفد صبرك يا حفيد عثمان الجزائر
انتم؟ روسيا تطلب من واشنطن هذا
الطلب وبشكل عاجل فما هذا الطلب
الاجراء. الصين تبادر باول خطوة
النظام العالمي الجديد واردوغان
وبعد ان قطعت نفطها؟ موسكو تهدد
بقرار كارثي جديد والرئيس
الطاقة? وماذا تريد فرنسا من
تايوان?
من وسط خمسين الف جندي يقولها
ابن الكريملين نحن هنا فاين